українські позиції в селищі Опитне під
бахмутом обороняють бійці чеченського
батальйону імені Джохара Дудаєва
нині ЗСУ відступили від селища бої
тривають у самому бахмуті разом з
українцями місто теж обороняють чеченці
або як вони себе називають ногті Ці
хлопці нещодавно повернулися з Донбасу
аби за кілька днів знову поїхати туди
для виконання бойових завдань бояться з
позивним мага воює у складі батальйону
Дудаєва він був ще дитиною коли
розпочалася перша Чеченська війна але в
бахмуті побачив багато схожого з подіями
на батьківщині
всюди у Росії один і той самий Почерк
треба було знищувати спершу усі
укріплення усі будівлі а потім уже йти
піхотою
Це точно так само як і в Чечні
і до перша хвиля піхоти вона гине друга
третя і коли доходить до сьомої восьмої
вони забирають якісь позиції і так вони
йдуть далі
м'ясо в них повно так що раби звикли так
жити
прививки жить так мага жив у Європі але
приїхав в Україну в 2016 році
питання що його мотивує воювати на
українському боці відповідає не
вагаючись
слова Джохара Дудаєва який сказав що
коли зійде українське сонце Росії більше
не буде І ми намагаємося підняти сонечко
ни
ні воюченських добровольчих підрозділів
один із них батальйон імені Шейха
мансура він з'явився у 2014 році бійці
підрозділу теж нині захищають Бахмут
2023 год
батальйону імені Джохара Дудаєва теж уже
9-й рік після повномасштабного
вторгнення його бійці звільняли Київщину
першими заходили до деокупованої
Балаклії на Харківщині
у батальйоні Дудаєва кажуть що усі
чеченські підрозділи співпрацюють між
собою у їхніх лавах є навіть українці
они воюют против нашего общего врага
вони воюють проти нашого спільного
ворога
і у нас в основному йдуть такі
мотивовані хлопці з Європи з Чечні
[музика]
є хлопці з Грузії дуже багато
от мы собираемся ось Ми збираємося і
додатково в нас нині йде набір
набор у нас идёт
охочі стати до лав батальйону Дудаєва
проходять відбір потім двомісячне
навчання значну увагу приділяють
фізичній формі й витривалості також у
бійців регулярно проходять тренування з
бойової підготовки батальйон не отримує
забезпечення від Української держави
Утім під час виконання завдань бійці
діють спільно з українськими
підрозділами й отримують від них усе
необхідне а також здобувають трофейну
зброю Як ось цю станину до кулемета
чеченські бійці батальйону не
розголошують свого громадянства хоча
більшість із них давно живуть в Україні
бійці бачать багато спільного між
чеченцями й українцями проблема в тому
що росіяни ніколи не сприймали українців
як рівних собі і ніколи нікого не
сприймали як рівних ми завжди були
якимось окремими Да ми тут іногда
ставкуємо ми іноді стикаємося із Скажімо
так залишковими проявами Русского Мира
коли деякі українці нас сприймають через
призму тієї пропаганди яка лилася проти
нас довгі роки І коли вони кажуть Я
думав ви такі Я таким людям кажу ти не
думав тобі сказали тобі сказало
російське телебачення тобі показали ці
дурні фільми російські де десятеро
російських солдатів обороняються від
3000 чеченських бойовиків
водночас бійці згадують українських
добровольців які поїхали воювати у Чечню
в 90 -х кажуть що приклад українців
мотивує їх і нині крім того чеченці
згадують спільну історію що
голодомора ще з часів голодомору коли в
Чечні приймали українських дітей
коли приходили голодні люди вони
проходили через Кавказ
тоді чеченці збирали цих дітей навчали
їх чеченській мові що нкведисти не могли
їх розрізнити
не могли их различить науковець Марат
ільясов який виїхав з Чечні після першої
чеченської війни і нині працює у США теж
проводить між українським і чеченським
народами історичні паралелі
Ми з одного пострадянського минулого і
це вже нас об'єднує ми страждаємо від
цього приблизно однаково українці
пережили геноцидний голод
більшість чеченців пережили геноцидну
депортацію і все це була справа рук
Радянського Союзу А до того обидва
народи постраждали від Російської
імперії що виглядало Приблизно так само
Марат Ілья член чеченської діаспори яка
налічує до півмільйона людей по всьому
світу більшість із них виїхали з Чечні
після приходу до влади рамзана Кадирова
за словами науковця нині у діаспори
немає єдиного лідера але є негативне
ставлення до Росії і підтримка України
ільясов сумнівається що в окупованій
Росії Чечні можливе повстання але
майбутнє його країни як і історія тісно
переплетені з Україною
у разі Перемоги України у що я щиро вірю
думаю логічно буде що Путіна усунуть від
влади як наслідок його усунення Кадиров
втратить підтримку і захист Кремля А це
відкриває можливості для людей які нині
в Європі не лише військових але й
політиків учених підприємців
інтелігенції для досить потужної
чеченської діаспори повернутися в Чечню
Якщо вони захочуть А це буде великим
кроком до здобуття чечнею незалежності
про незалежність для своєї держави
мріють і бійці які воюють в Україні Я
думаю що я думаю ми доб'ємося Свободи
уже 400 років у нас триває боротьба за
свободу покоління за поколінням іншала
на моєму поколінні це зупиниться
я мечтаю даже до того дня дожити до того
дня коли я в Україні не почую російську
мову якщо ти говориш російською щоб тебе
не зрозуміли як не розуміють російську
мову чехи поляки українською розуміють а
російську Ні тому що це імперська мова
штучна мова як і країна штучна і Ця
війна не скінчиться і не буде ніякого
мирного життя поки Росія буде існувати
як Росія російська Республіка нас
споконвічно російських територіях будь
ласка Живіть і нікому не заважайте для
командира батальйону Дудаєва це вже
третя війна з Росією він пройшов обидві
че ченські і каже що про втому від війни
нині не може бути мови ми вже 30 лет
войне мы как устали ми вже 30 років у
війні бути вільним це не просто так у
рабстві якщо люди хочуть жити це вже
Інше питання А ось за свободу треба
боротися Працювати треба і життя треба
віддавати